-Avant, j'étais étudiant aussi.
J'ai galéré pendant mes études.
Maintenant que je suis élu,
j'ai pas le pouvoir
de changer les choses,
parce que Macron et Le Pen
arrêtent pas de s'allier
contre les étudiants.
J'essaye quand même de continuer
de défendre.
-J'ai une question.
Comment t'as fait
pour te présenter ?
C'est quoi les démarches
que t'as faites ?
-J'ai été candidat
pour la France Insoumise.
Ensuite, il y a eu l'alliance
de tout le monde,
du coup, j'ai été élu comme ça.
Ca a été un enchaînement
de circonstances bizarre.
Etre élu à 21 ans quand on a juste
le BAC, et 10, en plus,
j'étais le premier choqué.
Musique entraînante
Hop.
Bonjour, je suis Louis Boyard,
député de la 3e circonscription
du Val-de-Marne.
On est à Villetaneuse
pour parler de précarité étudiante,
sujet sur lequel j'essaye
d'obtenir des victoires
à l'Assemblée nationale.
On va aller rencontrer
les étudiants
et parler de leurs galères
du quotidien.
-De Montpellier 3 à Rennes 2,
de Bordeaux Montaigne
à Amiens Picardie,
Louis Boyard écume les universités
de France
depuis son élection.
Il est aujourd'hui sur un campus
de Seine-Saint-Denis,
où l'Union étudiante,
un syndicat de gauche,
organise une distribution
alimentaire.
-Vous avez quoi, du coup ?
-Des fruits.
Il y a des kiwis,
il y a des concombres...
-Vous avez trouvé où, tout ça ?
-C'est venu du Crous.
-OK, trop bien.
Vous avez même des amandes.
Ca, ça va partir en 30 secondes.
Vraiment, moi, j'adore ça.
Heureusement que vous êtes là.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils demandent le plus,
les étudiants ?
C'est quoi le plus difficile
pour eux à obtenir ?
-Les fruits et les légumes,
par exemple,
ça aide beaucoup les étudiants,
parce que c'est quelque chose
qui pèse dans leur...
Pareil pour les conserves,
et les produits type amandes,
cookies,
les choses qui font plaisir
et qui coûtent cher.
-Oui. OK.
OK.
-Ce qui a pas été épargné
par l'inflation,
aussi, c'est les produits d'hygiène.
Le savon,
c'est de plus en plus cher.
On a essayé de faire un truc
un peu sympa,
avec des produits bio.
-Des étudiants
ont des parents qui leur donnent
de l'argent pour survivre.
Et encore, la plupart vivent
toujours sous le seuil de pauvreté,
et vous n'avez ceux
qui n'ont pas d'aide.
Quand vous prenez cette masse
d'étudiants-là,
vous découvrez l'océan
de précarité étudiante en France.
Quand vous allez à l'université,
vous vivez
avec 300, 400 euros par mois,
vous devez payer le loyer,
la nourriture,
les fournitures scolaires,
les transports.
C'est invivable.
Beaucoup craquent
et arrêtent leurs études.
Après, on leur dit :
"Vous êtes responsables."
Il y a une inégalité flagrante
à l'université.
La distribution alimentaire
en est le plus grand symbole.
-La précarité étudiante
est une réalité chiffrée.
En France,
1 jeune sur 4
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté,
et les étudiants
ne sont pas épargnés.
Ils sont 36 %
à sauter régulièrement
un repas, selon une étude
de l'association Cop1.
Le travail de Louis Boyard
consiste à mettre des visages
sur ces chiffres,
comme avec cet étudiant
fraîchement arrivé d'Angers.
-Je suis venu, j'y avais pas pensé,
mais un oreiller, une couette,
il y avait pas.
-Oui, les trucs de base.
-Oui, mais moi,
j'avais pas tout ça.
Ca m'a surpris.
-Oui.
-Après, la Navigo...
Une fois,
je voulais acheter des céréales.
Ca coûte cher.
Je mange pas, le matin.
Je mange tous les jours
des pâtes.
En fait, la viande...
J'ai pas de viande,
je peux plus.
-T'as l'impression
que l'Etat t'aide ?
-Le Crous à un euro,
ça m'aide vraiment.
-Oui. Mais tu peux l'avoir le soir ?
-Le soir, non, il y a pas,
dans mon secteur.
-Moi, à l'Assemblée,
j'ai proposé un revenu étudiant.
T'en penses quoi ?
-Un revenu étudiant ?
-Oui.
-Ca m'aiderait beaucoup,
pour mes études, pour vivre.
Même des fois,
je veux faire des sorties,
mais je peux pas les faire.
-Louis Boyard milite
pour une allocation d'autonomie
qui permette à chaque étudiant
de bénéficier
d'au moins 1102 euros par mois.
Le député a déposé
l'année dernière
une proposition de loi dans ce sens,
mais elle n'a pas été débattue
dans l'hémicycle.
-La principale barrière
qu'on a pour faire reconnaître
un revenu étudiant,
c'est que quand on dit :
"Si vous voulez que les étudiants
puissent étudier à égalité
"et vivre au-dessus
du seuil de pauvreté,
"arrêtez les bourses,
le salariat étudiant,
"il faut un revenu étudiant",
ce qu'on nous répond, c'est :
"Salariat étudiant, bourse..."
Quand on parle aux étudiants,
ça les handicape plus
qu'autre chose.
Un job étudiant, ça plombe.
C'est la première cause d'échec
en licence.
-Alors que le député est là
pour nous parler de précarité,
une demande inattendue
lui tombe dessus.
-Vous voulez que j'aille
dans l'amphi parler du Parlement ?
-La prof est pas encore là
pour le moment.
-Oui, mais est-ce que la prof
va être d'accord ?
-On lui a pas demandé.
-On y va.
-Allez, go.
-Allez.
Tu peux me prendre mon sandwich ?
Je vais pas faire cours avec
un sandwich au thon dans les mains.
-Elle est là.
-Elle vient d'arriver ?
J'étais venu parler
de distribution alimentaire,
mais les étudiants sont venus
me dire : "Viens...
-Oui, il y en a trois-quatre
qui ont rencontré leur star.
-J'ai dit :
"Je vais pas faire un cours."
-J'ai 2h30 de cours à faire
sur le Conseil constitutionnel
et j'ai déjà 10 minutes de retard.
Je vous laisse un quart d'heure ?
-OK. Avec grand plaisir.
-Et voilà comment le député
se transforme tout d'un coup
en maître de conférences.
-Bonjour. Merci beaucoup
de me laisser venir ici parler.
De base, c'était pas du tout prévu.
-Et c'est parti
pour une masterclass
totalement improvisée.
-Aujourd'hui, Macron,
et sa Première ministre, Borne,
ils ont pas 289 députés.
Ils ont pas la majorité,
donc du coup, pour faire passer
une loi, c'est la galère.
-Est-ce que, d'après toi,
une modification de la Constitution,
ça serait bien ou mal ?
-On peut modifier la Constitution
avec l'article 11.
Macron peut dire : "On va faire
un changement dans la Constitution."
-L'article 11, si.
Rires
-J'ai pas terminé
mes études de droit !
L'article 11,
c'est le référendum législatif.
On fera l'assemblée constituante
si notre programme est appliqué.
Il faut que j'aille
à la distribution alimentaire.
C'était chouette ! Bisous !
Applaudissements
-Je vais faire des références
à votre intervention
au 2nd semestre.
-OK. Bon courage pour le cours.
Merci.
Ils sont intéressés aux questions
de 6e République, de 49.3,
de ce qui se passe
autour de l'Assemblée nationale
et de la démocratie.
C'était intéressant et chouette,
comme échange.
C'est chouette de parler
d'autre chose
que de précarité étudiante.
-Passée cette parenthèse,
Louis Boyard retourne à son combat
pour les étudiants.
Il est cette fois au campus Pyramide
de Créteil,
toujours avec un représentant
syndical.
Il y a un an,
il s'était rendu dans cette fac
pour dénoncer des conditions
d'études délétères,
un autre volet
de la précarité étudiante.
Il revient sur les lieux pour voir
si la situation a évolué.
-Ici, le plafond
n'a pas été réparé.
On a ce genre de ventilation
et c'est complètement dégradé.
Ca tombe assez souvent,
on les retrouve par terre,
donc c'est à nous de les remettre.
C'est pareil juste de l'autre côté
du mur aussi.
Là aussi, il y a des travaux.
Le sol est pas adapté.
-OK. Et là, c'est les toilettes
où il y a pas de lavabo ?
-On peut pas se laver les mains.
-Ah oui, il y a vraiment...
Il y a pas de lavabo.
-Il y a pas de lavabo.
-Ils ont quand même été sympa,
ils ont mis du savon,
mais ils ont oublié les lavabos.
Il y a quand même des endroits, ici,
où les garçons sont obligés d'aller
dans les toilettes des filles,
dans une université française.
-Je sais pas
si ça s'entend dans la vidéo,
mais il y a des travaux.
Perceuse
Les étudiants sont censés travailler
dans ces conditions.
-On porte des doudounes
et j'ai un col roulé.
Il fait très froid, en fait.
C'est pas isolé.
L'hiver a pas commencé.
On cumule le froid,
l'absence de lavabo,
le fait que dans certains étages,
il y a pas d'eau,
la peinture
qui est faite que sur un mur,
les faux plafonds qui s'effondrent,
les travaux au sol, le bruit,
le manque d'information.
C'est tout ça qui fait
que vous êtes pas respectés.
-Les syndicats étudiants de Créteil
sont mobilisés depuis plusieurs mois
pour obtenir des avancées.
Le genre de combat que le député,
ancien représentant lycéen
puis étudiant connaît par coeur.
Il profite donc de sa visite...
-Bonjour !
-...pour donner quelques conseils
aux délégués de l'Unef.
-La rectrice nous a reçus.
On a fait une mobilisation.
On a pu tout lui dire sur le campus,
le Crous,
tout ce qu'on avait à dire.
-Déjà, vous avez réussi
à ramener la rectrice.
Bon, elle a fait 100 mètres.
Comment vous avez fait
pour la faire venir ?
-OK, trop bien.
Vous montrez une chose :
même si vous avez pas gagné,
- mais vous finirez par gagner -
la mobilisation, elle paye.
Tout est une question
de rapport de force.
La lutte paye.
Commencez
par une assemblée générale.
Tous les jeunes sont ensemble,
dans la même pièce.
Une fois qu'ils sont organisés
en nombre, il faut faire du bruit.
Pour faire du bruit,
il faut être visible.
Faites des vidéos,
des manifestations,
montrez-vous, alertez les gens.
Il y a rien que le gouvernement
et les hauts fonctionnaires
détestent plus qu'avoir
l'opinion publique contre eux.
Ensuite,
vous commencez le bras de fer.
-Et pour donner
un dernier coup de main à la lutte
avant de repartir,
la visite va se terminer
par un incontournable
de la méthode Boyard.
-Pas de lavabos, le faux plafond
tombe, il fait froid.
Bref : personne répond.
-Une vidéo destinée
aux réseaux sociaux :
l'autre grand terrain de lutte
du député.
-Regardez jusqu'où vont
les étudiants
pour se faire entendre.
Il y a personne,
au lycée Christophe Colomb.
Acclamations
-Avec 584 000 abonnés sur TikTok
et 105 000 sur Instagram,
il est l'un des députés
les plus suivis sur les smartphones.
C'est à l'Assemblée,
dans son bureau,
que Louis Boyard et son équipe
concoctent ces vidéos,
souvent percutantes.
Tout se joue au montage.
Le secret :
connaître les codes
des réseaux sociaux.
L'enjeu : toucher un public
jeune, qui ne s'intéresse
pas toujours à la politique.
-C'est très, très bien.
-On balance ça à 18 heures ?
-Let's go.
-Des changements de plans,
très dynamiques,
des plans progressifs,
beaucoup de cuts.
Des sous-titres très court,
pour que le mot
soit le plus court possible,
pour que l'oeil soit dynamique.
*-La rectrice est à 100 mètres.
On est caricaturés, on est moqués.
Certains m'appellent
"Député TikTok",
mais j'en ai pas honte.
Je porte la culture Internet
de ma génération à l'Assemblée,
et les jeunes attendent ça.
Le gouvernement
commence à s'y mettre.
Elisabeth Borne
commence à faire la même chose.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la nouvelle
manière de communiquer en politique.
Ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent,
ils critiquent mais ils cliquent.
-Influenceur,
lanceur d'alerte,
meneur de lutte,
Louis Boyard est très actif
dans les facs
et devant son écran.
Qu'en est-il de son travail
à l'Assemblée ?
Député de l'opposition,
il a eu des prises
de parole incisives.
-Face aux étudiants dans le besoin,
l'action de l'Etat est aussi pauvre
qu'un sandwich du Crous.
-Pour l'instant,
il n'a pas obtenu
de victoire législative
significative.
-Quand on a des moments
où je peux utiliser
le travail législatif
pour essayer de gagner des choses,
ça tombe à l'eau à cause du 49.3.
Quand je dois m'appuyer
sur d'autres textes
pour essayer de gagner,
ces textes apparaissent pas
car le Parlement ne débat pas
de précarité étudiante.
Puisque sur ce combat,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
c'est perdu d'avance,
je vais convaincre
d'autres personnes,
qui feront pression
sur le gouvernement.
Si ça ne fonctionne pas,
elles voteront pour nous.
Ensuite, on le mettra en place.
-Le groupe parlementaire
de la France Insoumise
prépare une nouvelle
proposition de loi
pour les étudiants.
Elle vise à répondre
à la crise du logement
chez les jeunes,
notamment en augmentant les APL.
Louis Boyard est signataire.
Le texte pourrait être étudié
dans les prochains mois.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA